hongrie à des migrants qui attendait
depuis plusieurs jours la possibilité de
prendre un trait on avait deux billets à
budapest pour aller gagner l'autre et le
site à pied qu'on a décidé de le faire
dans certains camps jean françois
bélanger
justement les suit j'entends des cris
venant que vous êtes avec ces gens qui
marchent vers viennent écouter ils ont
tous leurs effets personnels sur leur
dos et dans le sac à dos ils ont des
couvertures ils ont des vbz un peu d'eau
et ils ont décidé qu'il en avait assez
d'attendre à la gare de budapest
certaines sont coincés là depuis une
semaine certains même davantage ils ont
vu hier qui a deux trains qui sont
partis mais ils sont aussi l'autorité
les tromper leur ont menti à leurs
entreprises à aller vers la frontière
docu salah portrait des données vers des
camps où ils à être enregistrés quand
les gens n'ont plus du tout confiants
par les autorités en boîte
tout à l'heure ils se sont levés
ensemble donc bien haut parleurs ils ont
dit c'est assez on en a assez
on quitte maintenant nous partons à pied
pour la hongrie
c'est au moins cinq jours de marche
c'est vous dire à quel point ces gens là
qui sont vraiment désespérée oui et
jean-françois ça déchire les familles
d'ailleurs qui sont à prendre des
décisions de cet ordre là
et pourtant l'assist à des scènes
effectivement déchirante à la guerre
parce qu'il ya des gens qui voulaient
partir il ya des jeunes hommes qui sont
le en forme qui disent on va y aller
alors que des familles elle ya des
femmes et les enfants il ya des gars
qu'on regarde c'est dans la garde il ya
des enfants parmi eux qui ont trois ou
quatre ans comme ce petit garçon island
pour dick est mort il ya quelques jours
il ya de ces gens là comme ça imaginez
pour eux qu'est ce que ça représente que
de marcher comme ça pendant cinq jours
mais ils n'ont pas le choix de faire et
ne peuvent emprunter les transports ni
le talent ni les bus puisque les
autorités angoisse les empêche de le
faire tant qu'ils ont vraiment les
pressant sur rack n'ont plus d'avenir en
gris entendu ou s'il faut dire les
propos qu'est ce que tu une faute du
prêt ministre hongrois longtemps au ban
carrière a passé ses infinies c'est
infini sa comptine en temps il ya
plusieurs centaines de personnes je
parlais des femmes et des enfants
tant qu'ils ont entendu les propos de
monsieur viktor orban qui a dit en gros
que l'identité d'europe étaient menacées
par cet afflux de réfugiés
il a dit ce matin la radio tr min ce
qu'on voit donc actuellement on parle de
plusieurs centaines de milliers de
réfugiés mais que si on ne faisait rien
on avait parlé le jeu
millions de réfugiés l'année prochaine
et considère que sa vie est menacée en
fait l'identité chrétienne de l'europe
si les propos du premier ministre
hongrois viktor orban nos gars c'est
choquant aux yeux de beaucoup de chefs
d'état européens qui viennent plutôt
pour plus d'ouverture pour que l'europe
ouvre les portes à ces migrants là c'est
réfléchir ces demandeurs de tête
réfugiés là alors que la hongrie
clairement leur ferme les portes et
reald mur et on voit l'armée même à la
frontière et oui et des murs qui sont
non pas virtuel mais vraiment de vrai
mur et on voit ce matin et le parlement
de budapest qui a adopté une nouvelle
législation qui vise à contrôler
davantage l'arrivée des migrants jeu
drôle là on a adopté dès raffermi donc
les lois les migrants ne se sentent pas
libier vu en fait en hongrie
c'est clair on veut tous aller en
allemagne
on s'est engueulés merkel envoyer des
propos plutôt rassurants pour tous ces
migrants là aussi qu'à son généralement
la gare qu'elle a parlé hier aux
français qu'en soient les deux se sont
entendues pour établir des quotas de
vigan que chaque pays européen devrait
accueillir des quotas obligatoires à
respecter pour ça que des pays ça ne
fait pas la peur de 28 pays l'union
européenne par carla qui sont contre la
hongrie fait partie de ces pays là qui
ne se refuse à recevoir donc un quota
déterminé de migrants donc c'est clair
l'europe ne parle pas d'une seule voix
le rap est vraiment déchiré plus que
jamais avec cette victoire des migrants
la plus grave crise en fait de
migrateurs depuis la seconde guerre
mondiale jean-françois l'image de venir
vous là et on veut pas la simplifier on
a l'impression que c'est la sortie d'un
stade qui a des gens c'est infini
s'arrête pas c'est renversant de vous
voir et vous entendre et de voir tous
ces gens là et certains d'entre eux qui
ont été leurrés hier dans la sphère des
deux trains qui sont partis le
gouvernement est un peu un peu coincé là
est un peu pris à son jeu parce que là
on les arrête commun maintenant là parce
que quand ils sont dans la bulle
réécoutez clair regardez c'est clair que
les autorités ont été prises par
surprise par la décision soudaine de
partir on voit les policiers qui
accompagnent un peu on en voit ici et là
mais ils ne se contentent de demander
ses deux balises et de canaliser ce flot
de migrants qui marche comme ça c'est
clair en fait n'était pas
l'intention de ces gens là que de partir
de par les autorités par surprise parce
que j'ai dit tout à l'heure ils ne font
plus du tout confiance aux haut rhinois
aux autorités hongroises ni pour assurer
leur sécurité ni même pour leur dire la
vérité parce qu'ils ont été
on leur a menti déjà à plusieurs
reprises des gens ici n'ont plus du tout
confiance dans les autorités hongroises
ont tous restés allez on y va on peut et
on s'en va et c'est certainement le
meilleur là bas ont fait le minimum on
voyait et vous marchez juste à côté
d'elle cette femme d'un certain âge qui
a des bagages sur la tête alors ils sont
partis avec l'essentiel ce sont
principalement des syriens qui déjà
étaient réfugiés dans leur propre pays
qui ne veulent pas de ces camps de
réfugiés écouter ces gens là ont
parcouru des milliers des milliers de
kilomètres l'ont fait la plupart d'entre
eux ont fait cinq pays
ils sont passés par en quittant donc la
syrie sont allés en turquie certains
sont allés au divan c'est le cas de
beaucoup de syriens
ils ont vu qu'il n'avait pas beaucoup
d'avenir l'abaya pas de travail là bas
là encore temps de traverser un pont qui
mène vers l'autoroute ces gens là vont
se rendre en autriche par l'autoroute
imaginer un pied donc ensuite ces gens
là on se sont sont arrivés en grèce ils
ont traversé la mer egée en bateau dans
des conditions extrêmement dangereuses
exactement les mêmes conditions qui ont
coûté la vie à ce petit island pour dit
donc tous ces gens là ici à paris ont
traversé eux mêmes cette mer egée en
bateau dans des conditions effroyables
ensuite ils ont traversé la serbie ils
sont à la macédoine la serbie ils sont
arrivés ici donc vous dites ça ne leur
fait pas peur
les kilomètres à pied ça ne leur fait
pas peur ils n'ont rien à perdre
selma renversant vous venez nous
chercher avec ces images là jean
françois roubaud vous laisser faire ce
gain les garder ici regardez trop la vie
une famille complète et qui ont tous du
corps d'effets personnels finalement son
petit chariot db un petit poucet de bb
bb- latin ça sinon on va suivre pour
vous bon évidemment m'attendre et
ensuite à on ne les quitte pas on va
savoir que tu vas tu avais que vous avez
un rôle important à jouer j'ai
l'impression que les gens se sentent
soutenus quand il voit les journées
poussines étrange et très certainement
bien je te sens dans tout cas protéines
et dans les pays baltes et ne vont pas
les frapper si jamais il ya des médias
et donc merci à vous et à votre équipe
fantastique jean-françois merci beaucoup
mais il faut souvent mais je suis un peu
bouleversé parce que ça sent déjà comme
vous serrez les petites fusées